so bob woodward and robert costa have a
new book titled peril
and in this book there's a bit of a
shocking revelation the shocking
revelation is that general mark melody
the chairman of the joint chiefs of
staff assured his chinese counterpart
general li zhou chang of the people's
liberation army that the united states
would not strike
apparently he did this twice apparently
he was so fearful twice in the final
months of the trump administration
that the president's action might spark
a war with china he moved urgently to
avert armed conflict okay so number one
you have to ask yourself where did this
story come from and where did the story
come from because apparently there's
only two people on that phone call one
is mark milley and the other
is general lee chang of the people's
liberation army presumably woodward
didn't get this from the chinese which
means that mark millie is bragging about
this which is not a shock because mark
milley has a greatly inflated sense of
both his own importance and of the
historical moment right mark milley was
the one who was comparing january 6 to
an actual restag fire and suggesting the
entire democracy was in danger which of
course wasn't true
he he has this kind of bizarre
blown-up sense of himself
as the man standing in the gap standing
in the breach
okay so but even if you believe that
there are ways to resist
presidential illegal orders
and number one you don't carry them out
number two you can threaten to quit
we actually have precedent for this
during the trump administration
even if it's not illegal you can
threaten to quit james mattis did it
several times before he actually quit
right the secretary of defense general
james mattis
you'll recall that donald trump wanted
him to do particular things that he
didn't want to do in syria and mattis
just went to him and was like i'm not
doing that
and then trump backed down well millie
could have done the same thing he didn't
he didn't even go to congress
right milly apparently went directly to
the enemy he went directly to the
chinese government
and he said to them you know this crazy
guy in the white house man that guy's
crazy and uh and if he orders us to do
anything militarily even if it's legal
i'm just not gonna do it in fact i will
call you first
i will call you first and then you
wonder why so many conservatives worry
about the quote unquote deep state coup
cause that sounds an awful lot like a
deep state clue i mean even alexander
vinman right the guy who is
who is phoning in the ukraine phone call
very anti-trump even he was like this is
insane because it is civilian control of
the military is a bulwark of american
republicanism okay so according to bob
woodward's book
the chairman of the joint chiefs of
staff under president trump general mark
milley called up
the
head of the chinese military general
liao chang
and told him the united states would not
strike one call according to the
washington post took place on october
30th 2020 four days before the election
that unseated president trump
the other took place january 8 2021 and
two days after the capital siege carried
out by his supporters in a quest to
cancel the vote
the first call was prompted by millie's
review of intelligence suggesting the
chinese believed the united states was
preparing to attack that belief the
author's right was based on tensions
over military exercises in the south
china sea and deepened by trump's
belligerent rhetoric toward china
millie apparently called up general lee
he said quote i want to assure you the
american government is stable and
everything is going to be okay we are
not going to attack or conduct any
kinetic operations against you
in the books account millie went so far
as to pledge he would alert his
counterpart in the event of a u.s attack
stressing the report they'd established
through a back channel general lee you
and i have known each other for five
years now if we're going to attack i'm
going to call you ahead of time it's not
going to be a surprise
that's insane
and we're not even talking about
post-election at this point this is
still pre-election it's before ending
the january 6 stuff just before any of
the election fraud stuff none of which
by the way justifies breaking the chain
of command in illegal ways which is
apparently what mele did to do this well
but again this is even before any of
that this is october 30th
now
i recall that period i recall october
november december january wasn't that
long ago
was that widespread talk about how the
united states was going to enter a
full-scale fighting war with the chinese
was that even on the table was anybody
even discussing that like i feel like i
would have heard about that given the
fact that president trump is a big
devotee to cable news
and cable news presumably would have
been discussing that pretty rapidly if
trump were talking about it like
what were the actual possibilities that
the chinese thought that we were going
to start a shooting war with a country
with a billion humans in it
like what
does anyone actually believe that or is
miley just a delusional
thoroughly self-obsessed human being
and is it insane i mean that's insane
that he called up the chinese
even if you believed that the elements
of surprise is a bit of a thing in a war
let's say that trump had issued an
actual legal order to fire on a chinese
boat in the south china sea
is miley actually going to warn the
chinese that we're about to do that
losing the fundamental element of
surprise in a military conflict
also the notion that milly would have to
call the chinese is crazy
because again we do have procedures to
defy illegal orders in the military
cnn reported on this back in september
of 2018.
based on another bob woodward book
actually
because a couple of years ago there's a
bob woodward book
talking about how james mattis was
mouthing off about trump and all of the
rest of this
but cnn reported at the time
that all of the top u.s commanders would
push back against an order from trump
for a nuclear strike if it were quote
unquote illegal
general john heighten who's the top u.s
nuclear commander
said quote i provide advice to the
president he'll tell me what to do if
it's illegal guess what's going to
happen i'm going to say mr president
that's illegal guess what he's going to
do he's going to say what would be legal
and we'll come up with options of a mix
of capabilities to respond to whatever
the situation is that's the way it works
it's not that complicated
heighten emphasized the us military has
the obligation to follow only legal
orders including those entailing the
launch of nuclear weapons
also
air force general robert keeler who
served as commander of u.s
u.s strategic command under obama said
there are layers of safeguards within
the system designed to ensure any order
is legal and proportionately appropriate
quote u.s nuclear forces operate under
strict civilian control only the
president of the united states can order
the employment of u.s nuclear weapons
this is a system controlled by human
beings nothing happens
automatically cnn military analyst john
kirby right now he's the spokesperson
person for the pentagon but at that
point he was a military analyst for cnn
he said that military judge advocates in
general counsel are active participants
in the decision-making process at
virtually every level from the tactical
to the strategic
he said they help ensure political
appointees and uniformed commanders
fully understand and consider law of war
principles as well as the dictates of
congressional legislation before any
final decision is reached regarding the
use of armed force and defense of the
nation particularly during the planning
of combat operations so in other words
is there any circumstance under which it
would have been necessary for an
american general to go to the chinese
and say we're going to give you a heads
up on a military attack
how is that not borderline treason
i mean no matter how much you hate trump
let's say you're a democrat do you want
that same logic being applied to joe
biden do you want the generals to start
calling up
targets of american military ira and
being like yeah guys you know we're not
going to abandon those orders and if
biden threatens you it's an empty threat
in the second call place to assuage
chinese fears about the events of
january 6th lee wasn't as easily as wage
even after merely promised him quote we
are 100 steady everything's fine but
democracy can be sloppy sometimes we
remained rattled millie who did not
relate the conversation to trump
understood why the chairman 62 at the
time chosen by trump in 2018
believed the president had suffered a
mental decline after the election the
authors write a view he communicated to
house speaker nancy pelosi in a phone
call january 8.
he agreed with her evaluation trump was
unstable according to a call transcript
obtained by the authors now
again that's not illegal right millie is
allowed to talk to nancy pelosi what
he's not allowed to do is call up the
chinese and start conveying this stuff
believing that china could lash out if
it felt at risk from an unpredictable
and vengeful american president millie
took action the same day he called the
admiral overseeing u.s indo-pacific
command the military responsible for
asia and pacific and recommended
postponing military exercises in the
admiral complied millie also summoned
senior officers to review the procedures
for launching nuclear weapons saying the
president alone could give the order but
also that he millie had to be involved
which is a bit of a violation of the
chain of command looking each in the eye
milly asked the officers to affirm that
they had understood in what he
considered an oath
milly went furthest in seeking to stave
off a national security crisis but his
alarm was shared throughout the highest
ranks of the administration including
cia director gina haspel who told millie
quote we are on the way to a right-wing
coup
a right-wing coup
again there was no institutional support
for the january sixth rioters and in
fact it was a bunch of republicans who
signed off on the election in the states
and in the federal government as well
okay now all of this is deeply dangerous
stuff as i'm suggesting if you have an
administrative bureaucracy unelected
officials who are actually making the
policy of the united states in
opposition to the elected leaders of the
united states
you have on your hands a real threat to
democracy an actual coup
right the threat to democracy lies in
unelected bureaucrats not a part of the
judicial branch or at least appointed
and voted on unelected bureaucrats
making policy in defiance of their
democratically elected bosses that's a
serious problem
and we have procedures for people saying
they don't want to follow illegal orders
what we don't have are procedures for
you calling up a foreign power and
trying to define foreign policy on your
own as an appointee of the president of
the united states in defiance of statute
and millie needs to go and he needs to
go forth with maybe he needs to be
prosecuted i mean that's that's insane
stuff
and that would hold true regardless of
who the president of the united states
is nonetheless the hatred for trump
means and this is where we are in our
politics hatred for trump means that the
democratic left expects quote unquote
deep state actors to do this sort of
stuff
they expect people in the administrative
bureaucracy to thwart republicans this
is why the ratchet only works one way
and again it's not only true when it
comes to the military infrastructure
it's true when it comes to osha it's
when it comes to the epa it's true when
it comes to the irs the ratchet only
works one way because when a republican
is in office an entire executive branch
exists to thwart him and when a democrat
exists to placate a swage and forward
all of his policy proposals
here's democratic representative john
garamendi
from california defending millie's
reported actions
i'm talking about what general milly did
you think that that's legitimate that he
would call a secret meeting and say
don't listen to the commander-in-chief
basically
i believe that millie would do that
now did he do it well that remains to be
seen but i what i know of that uh
general
and his role as chief of staff is that
he would
call the meeting
given the concerns of an unhinged
president uh
at that period of time
okay so um there they are apparently
this is all okay
msnbc's barry mccaffrey who of course is
a general himself he said well you know
it's fine he's just trying to stop world
war three
i think what general miller was doing
and by the way routinely the chairman
the service chiefs the joint combatant
commanders routinely are in contact
with their counterparts globally part of
the
the deterrence of unwanted combat
uh i think he felt it important to not
end up with a world war one
start of a war through miscalculation on
the part of the chinese so again i think
we ought to be fortunate we got this
princeton grad tremendous combat officer
extremely intelligent law based trying
to safeguard the transition to a dually
elected president by the administration
now we do have diplomats
right we have diplomats who are
available
why didn't
why didn't he walk across the the office
millie to
folks in the state department and say to
the secretary of state mike pompeo you
know there might be a miscalculation
here you might want to call up the
chinese and assure them that there is no
imminent military action
and the idea here is that millie was
working he was the man on the inside
okay cnn's lieutenant general mark
hurtling also defended millie
and i'm not sure how you defend the
general who is calling up the enemy and
trying to inform them about how he is
going to essentially create the military
policy on his own in defiance of the
civilian leadership
i think general miller took some very
prudent measures general milley isn't
going to call the the head of the
people's liberation army in china and
say hey don't worry about everything's
going on he's getting signals that other
countries are concerned as well they
should have been during this period of
time they were all watching what was
going on in the insurrection on the 5th
of january so i think general milley
didn't limit the president's power
i think if he did that would be
certainly a civil military action of of
the highest highest measure and should
be condemned but what he did was ensure
the guard rails were in place so i give
him high marks for this based on what's
described in the book
high marks okay again him going to
members of the military brass and saying
okay there's still a chain and here's
how the legalities work that's fine i
really don't have a huge problem with
that
whether it's called for or not that's
that's within his purview i'm gonna keep
focusing on he called up the chinese
government
right after they had unleashed by the
way worldwide virus he called up the
chinese government
and told them
about what america's military plans
would or would not be this of course led
president trump to fire back he was
president trump yesterday
first of all if it is actually true
which is hard to believe uh that he
would have called
china and done these things and was
willing to advise them of an attack or
in advance of an attack that's treason
for him to say
that i would even think about attacking
china i think he's trying to just get
out of his incompetent withdrawal out of
afghanistan
okay so trump is not wrong about this
and it does speak to the fact that once
the bureaucracy is entrenched it stays
entrenched
how's this for a title ben shapiro show
subscriber destroys like button with
clicks and logic i'd watch that make it
happen gang